So first off, the server-client model.
We've talked about this in previous sessions,
if you've watched any of the previous ones,
but Unreal operates on an authoritative server model.
So what that means is that really what the server says goes,
the server maintains the actual true state of things.
Obviously, there's a discrepancy here when you're not doing multiplayer games.
That's referred, let's say, kind of like,
configuration that's referred to as standalone.
That essentially means you are playing the game locally,
meaning the client and server are essentially the same thing.
So in the situation of single or local multiplayer,
there is a single, the client machine is essentially the server's machine.
There's really no server.
But it's worth mentioning that very, very early on,
we talked about the idea that we had,
I think this is in the first training session,
we have these different pragmas that you could use to define
whether or not the code you're working in is server code or client code.
And that is true when you're in standalone or when you're in editor,
that is true for both, both of those things are true.
It is both client and server.
So hypothetically, in standalone,
when you're playing just a single-player game or a local multiplayer,
you are kind of a client and a server.
So in that situation, the client is authoritative.
We'll talk about what authority specifically means shortly.
But yeah, it has full control over everything.
All the data is local.
We don't have to worry about data going to any other computers,
to any other clients or the server.
And we don't have to worry about data importantly coming from anywhere.
Then we have the kind of other situation, which is a network setup.
And what that means is the server is always fully authoritative
and players that connect to the server are kind of referred to as clients.
And as we said, it's the server that holds the true state of the game.
In that situation, the kind of all relevant gameplay logic
is and definitely should be local to the server.
But there are aspects of data that would be kind of remote
that either the server just doesn't care about
or technically the client would have authority over.
Again, we'll talk about those in a little bit.
And then there's also another configuration to kind of bear in mind
where one of the players can be simultaneously the client and the server.
We'll talk about that a little bit more in a bit.
So the types of servers.
We've got dedicated, which is the kind of standard setup
for a lot of the kind of competitive games you'll be playing online.
So in this context, the server runs an entirely distinct machine.
The server would run in a kind of headless configuration
some people might refer to it as.
This essentially means that the server doesn't need to be doing any of the things
you as a player would typically care about in a game.
It doesn't need to be listening for input.
It doesn't need to render visuals.
There are no local clients on this machine.
So all the server is really there to do is process input changes
like messages that might be coming from clients
kind of ticking the game over
and just maintaining that authoritative state of the game
and then dispatching that information to each of the connected clients.
It receives information from clients to verify,
so that might be things like inputs and then clients informing them
where the client thinks that their location is.
And then alternative to that, we have the listen server.
This is what I was just referring to a minute ago.
This is essentially where a single client will also act as server.
So this is not really a suitable setup for anything
that is meant to be certainly competitive games
or anything with a lot of players playing locally,
with a lot of players playing in a single session.
It's not because of the kind of additional costs
of rendering a screen, listening for input,
hosting on additional kind of client configuration.
There's only a kind of, there's a more limited subset of situations
where a listen server is really acceptable.
Most of the time that's going to be probably more cooperative games
because it's probably relatively obvious that if you are a listen server,
your ping is going to be close to zero.
So you're going to have a massive advantage
over other players connected to your game.
So if you're in a competitive environment,
that's probably not going to be suitable.
And also when you're, even if you are doing a,
some kind of cooperative game at scale,
purely the extra cost put on your CPU
of having to do all those kind of local client calculations,
it's just going to mean that it's not necessarily
such a suitable configuration.
So dedicated server is going to be suitable for all situations.
Listen server is admittedly easier to set up,
but is really only going to be suitable for probably non-competitive,
probably small scope, like no more than, you know,
four to eight players maybe, kind of set up.
The other thing about dedicated server,
you might be familiar with this term is that, you know,
some games would choose to give out a copy of their game
where you can turn your own computers into dedicated servers.
So it depends, that's kind of a design decision on you as a developer
of whether or not you want to expose the functionality
to host, for players to host their own dedicated servers
or whether you want, you know, the acquisition of dedicated servers
to be something that you purely do as a kind of proprietary thing
where people would have to either purchase servers
or you as a developer take on the responsibility
of hosting all dedicated servers for your game.
So just talking about like how someone actually, you know,
when a client is trying to join, connect to a server,
let's just talk a little bit about how that process actually goes.
There's actually a very good post in Unreal documentation,
which I can kind of come back to, that kind of goes through
a little bit in kind of more detail, but in the kind of like,
in the broad scope of things, yeah, we just kind of go,
worth going over this kind of high level flow.
So the first step is we have our client make a request
for a connection to our server.
At that point, the server can reject,
accept or reject that connection request.
There's some kind of like handshaking that goes on.
And then once the connection is accepted,
the server is going to send information down
to the client for them to proceed.
At that point, the server is going to kind of
tell the client what map to load
and then proceed to wait for the client to load the desired map.
And once the server receives that callback,
the pre-login function is called in the game mode.
We talked about this in I think our second session
about the kind of game flow.
And it's critical step, this kind of pre-login function,
because it's at that point that you can inject gameplay code
that can kind of choose to accept or reject that connection.
So whilst we said the server decides to accept or reject
the connection very early in the flow,
that is not something that you as a developer
would typically have access to
unless you went changing engine code.
The kind of point at which you as a developer
would typically inject that the kind of capability
to reject or accept a connection
is going to be in the game mode base pre-login function,
which you can obviously override
in your game mode classes.
If that is then accepted by your pre-login,
we then go on to call login game mode.
And it's a login that we would call,
we would create the player controller on the server.
And it's, you know, as with all of this flow,
we'll talk a little bit more about this,
but whenever you create actors on the server,
those actors are then kind of inherently replicated to the client.
So that login function will create the player controller on the server
and that then gets replicated to the client.
It's also really important to note that the player controller
will get its begin play called.
So it's just understanding, like it's important to understand
where that's going to occur in that flow.
It would be at this point.
And then lastly, the server is going to call post login
on the game mode.
And that's basically the point at which it's now safe
to call RPC functions on the player controller.
You can expect those functions.
We've not talked really about what RPCs are yet,
but it's at the point of post login getting called
that we can be certain that that connection is set up,
that the client has that player controller,
and therefore RPCs are going to kind of flow through to that client.
As I said, there's a kind of more detailed post.
I believe it's actually by a member of the community,
not an Epic dev themselves,
but it just goes into this flow in more detail
and more granular function by function call.
You'll actually see this in the presenter notes.
So if you're more interested in more specific detail about this,
there's a good post about this on the Epic community forums.
And that's actually part of the presenter notes in this presentation.
So if you're interested in following up on that,
just follow that link in the presenter notes.